[Music]
and bloody commitment hmm
submitted by Hannah banana p5 Oh Donna
haha Nevada cephas banana this couple
forgoes wedding rings and this dead
drinks each other's blood as a sign of
their love and commitment I thought we
were Siri
that's cute they're original I thought
they're gonna drink each other's piss I
think that's actually more commitment in
the blood yeah or eat each other's [ __ ]
just a little bit a little bit
it should just tell it no because
thinking is so blood it's like who
doesn't like blood right it's medium
rare it's like everyone has blood all
the time okay so it's normal [ __ ] you
guys already swap spit because you guys
make up you guys have each other's
[ __ ] googoo juices in each other's
mouths all the time Google juice is the
Q term for come if you really want to
show each other how much you love each
other has to be the worst part of
yourself he's better so if each person
you guys ever seen [ __ ] where has all
the wrinkles in it right I like the
wrinkle like to wrinkle [ __ ] just peel
off a nugget put it on a fork and then
[ __ ] wedding thing right do this do
one of these things I think that'd be
really like easy guys I would be down
it's for marriage if I'm trying to prove
my money I'm gonna feed my love it might
am I trying to be a little [ __ ] or my
child prove my love be a little [ __ ]
it's okay yeah and to make it
ceremonious you have to like get it in a
lipstick and then so you take it out and
the [ __ ] comes out and you put it on and
they put it on bears and then you
consummate the marriage by [ __ ]
kissing which [ __ ] all over each other
final violent or how about we just
change wings I like that idea
no that's what I'm saying like if you
want to keep it normal keep it normal
but if you want to like the next level
the next level I don't like your next
level like be a tube if you if you if
regulars one point oh right you
shouldn't be next level 2.0
do 2.0 don't do it one point one that's
what I'm saying
oh man hear that [ __ ] gauge is 0 and
then 89 messages
that is only said levels we do by the
way that's a [ __ ] said let's just drink
mercury I know when you go drink alcohol
is a poison right history mercury then
[ __ ] of a wheel drunkards of this
couple they're an Italian couple of
course why I don't know they're
passionate
oh yeah you know by the way though real
quick Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie
already did the exchanging of blood
thing
it wasn't Brad Pitt was Billy Joel Billy
Bob Thornton really bullheaded in a vial
yeah because they drink yourself I don't
know about that I know they just carried
their blood with each other I used to
love Angelina Jolie continue yes nodded
cultural uh-huh their names art so it's
Dennis diminished thirty year olds named
Dennis and his 20 year old girlfriend
named ilaria who is pregnant yet ten
years they've been together for three
years so since she was 17 mom and they
met because he was advertising for an
assistant for his circus act his circus
act juggled like balls in your mouth
cause they drink club so they're other
vampires they're vampires now remember
just like Amy Winehouse what they're
vampires yeah yeah like that there are
they a part of the vampire world yes I
guess yeah okay because they have like
implanted pain I wanted those in high
school you were one of those Hot Topic
kids I never shot that topic dude if you
had fangs that you were cool you didn't
shot at not hopping all right where did
you shop cool girl to me Laura
you guys go to Melrose you had to go to
Hollywood had a hunt down your [ __ ] and
yet it be original oh my gosh I've never
heard of cool girls learning like things
though I know I know but that's just how
cool I was I want a band it's true oh
cool she was not a part of the cool
crowd that I was so cool you can't find
any picture of me in the [ __ ]
yearbook
you know what it's fine
that all because like I was going to be
a vampire you still a vampire I know a
baptize of all over the world okay how
do you say blood in Spanish hanging
around McDonald tells [ __ ] dope it's
like a sangria that sounds dope oh I'm
not really impressed because they're not
eating each other's [ __ ] well now you
know why because they're vampires not
[ __ ] [ __ ] eaters they're not looking
- ten I don't write this couple of day
they're hygienic vampires because they
use alcohol i sterilize all their
needles and everything what they was how
was possible thank God they drive to his
blood
glass vials and then they drink them
every day or like one time sure how
often but they didn't mention that sure
she drinks more of his blood because he
said that like her drawing blood so much
is going to ruin her perfect body or
something like that where I'm thinking
like she's ingesting your blood though
isn't that ruining her body - maybe she
needs the extra I ordered the PMS face
that's right I think biologically
speaking it's kind of weird just because
it's kind of borderline animal is
anabolism and uh usually species don't
get more nutrients from feeding on the
same species like species have to eat
other species to get other nutrients so
biologically it's not going to enrich
any of their bodies I think but
psychologically psychologically possibly
new merch is a Haunter saying that blood
is a mythological bodily juice that for
them it means life and so that's why
they drink each other's blood as a sign
of their bond just as married couples
wear rings that's a logically if that's
what they want that's fine if Zeus says
do it do it if that's their myth math
girls go ahead miss Mendez mr. Beck is
my mythical macros and I'm sponsoring
blah I like it they are consenting
adults they could do whatever they want
and on top of that they're doing it
responsibly hygienic Lee so they're
being badass but like responsibility you
know yeah
we're gonna live on the wild side but
we're gonna be responsible I like that
it's not my cup of tea
however I liked how they're just
confident and they're just like we're
we're despot deal with it so my dad is
cool okay I respect it I really just
don't give two [ __ ] I don't care it's
like hey you know what I do I drink
blood like all right [ __ ] loser get
away from me
thanks for the information [ __ ] idiot
thanks pal I think this this articles
written for my grandma why because
people like my grandma's going to read
this and go oh my goodness the world is
a mysterious place there's people like
this out there before us it's like man I
already heard of people eating blood
like well that's why the next-level [ __ ]
is eating [ __ ] there's blood like if you
want to Vietnamese restaurant there's
[ __ ] porks blood cubes they're
delicious blood is like I'm such a
normal B I'm diabetic so it's what I
think for like Asian person it's like
what do you mean like I grew up in a
[ __ ] your name [ __ ] taken clear I
don't need to be bonded to somebody like
that dude I'm straight-up okay I don't
even want wedding rings bro that's a
waste I don't know I feel like
situations like this - like if they
think there's such a big deal slightly
positive don't nobody [ __ ] cares get
away from me mmm you know this is like
really that information that you really
have to tell somebody like nobody is
going to ask you straight up not buy it
by the way I'm not sure if you do this
[Music]
like nobody should have that they're
volunteering this information to people
well as part of their ass actually like
they go onstage and they also their show
off now yeah so they do this on stage
but what this article is pointing out is
that they don't only do it on stage they
also do it outside and what I gotta pack
ah ah how do they have so much blood to
me aw I thought I loved
file I mean every time you go get your
blood drawn it's like four or five last
question how much they make him though
for me I don't know that they're making
like six figures she's I know but I do
not they're on tour and currently their
show is in Germany who the [ __ ] wants to
see that they're a circus yeah that's
not circus enough though yeah the back
is magua Dennis and pretty pistols
that's their name what else do they do
yeah I don't know it just doesn't they
just dress up and they act like blood
sucking creatures that's it I want to be
some joggling man some magic like a
thanks we drew the blood through magic
and then it is levitated levitate it
with sound oh yeah would that be cool
see right now I guarantee you like the
Elephant Man would scoff at these people
say listen man if you don't know that
l-jamaa here you're like yeah I waited
like elephantitis all over he looked
good
just this Michael Jackson has skeleton
yeah yeah and there's like a famous
saying he was all about the bones go oh
I'm a scuba dude yeah it's not on me
yeah so old black and white Tom yeah he
needs to wear like a bag when he said
yeah he wore a bag around the elephant
man who was a real circus attraction
would make fun of these people guys
yeah all the freaks were the sideshow
like the wolf people they have hair all
over their body and they legit look like
well does the Angelina you guys are
faint you weren't even born with those
things what's up you sexy [ __ ]
useless [ __ ] [ __ ] if you
want to follow us you could check out
all our [ __ ] link to the description
box below you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then that videos are up there
you